hello
my name is ken bogen i'm going to be
talking about
mathematica applications to quantitative
toxicology
and environmental health risk assessment
i've been applying mathematica to that
general area
through my career of 20 years at
lawrence livermore national laboratory
10 years as a managing scientist at
exponent a worldwide consulting firm
and uh since then as a board certified
toxicologist
in private practice and then briefly for
a year and a half
over the last two years
working for one of our federal agencies
here in the washington dc area
involved in biosurveillance
i have an abstract associated with the
talk
uh it's included in the presentation
which you can download
from the conference schedule
the entire mathematica presentation uh
is there i'm just scrolling through the
presentation
notebook uh
to form this uh the talk and uh but
i will uh skip
reading the abstract you can get it
there and uh
go right into the first of the four
areas
which involves the the risk of olfactory
neuron
killing by zinc nasal gel
so assessing that risk involves
determining whether the toxicity of zinc
to olfactory neurons
may occur through either the deposition
of aerosolized
droplets uh direct deposition of the gel
stream
onto the olfactory epithelium which is
located at the apex or top
of the nasal cavity here shown here
and also toxicity can occur by diffusion
of zinc
from the gel along the surface of the
nasal cavity
and potentially eventually reaching the
olfactory epithelium
before the gel is cleared by the normal
action of mucociliary clearance
which drives material along the surface
of the epithelium along the
mucosal surface uh backward and downward
uh toward the throat
and the rate of that is known so that's
built into
the consideration here uh the the first
issue of aerosolization i addressed
experimentally by demonstrating
that almost none of an applied gel
stream is
actually aerosolized and
potentially aerosolized in the form of
droplets
that are small enough to float in air
so that turned out not to be an issue so
we examined
more closely using mathematica the
direct
uh deposition of the stream
onto the epithelial surface and
diffusion
along the nasal cavity surface
potentially to
the olfactory epithelium now zinc
toxicity
is defined in terms of toxic load which
is the product
of a power of concentration times time
and it was
using available experimental data
able to characterize
the toxic loads uh toxic load magnitudes
that would be likely to kill
olfactory human
neurons and so using that information
we could then look at these two issues
of direct deposition
and diffusion to uh
examine the the likelihood of
olfactory neuron damage
um and the anosmia that that would
cause which is the
loss of the sense of smell
to define the potential for that outcome
quantitatively and so here what we did
to do this was
use a very detailed model published by a
group in canada
in 2009 uh involving uh
a half a million vertex
model a three-dimensional model at a
half a millimeter
resolution uh based on mris taking of 30
uh adults male and female
and the vertices then could be used to
examine
the issue of direct deposition
um here you're seeing the nasal model
uh here you see half of the nasal cavity
which is divided into by a septal wall
uh the middle of the nasal cavity so
here you see the septal wall and then
rotating
we see the lateral wall here
a very complex geometry to the human
nasal cavity
um making this a challenging exercise
but
facilitated by mathematica's 3d
imaging capabilities
and we can see that injecting a
stream of nasal gel
into the nasal cavity in a way that
would
deposit onto the olfactory epithelium
is uh not really possible
because there's a bow shaped curvature
to the septal wall that prevents a
stream of gel from shooting up that far
so we are
then left with the
analysis of zinc concentration
by diffusion over the surface of the
nasal epithelium
as a potential pathway to neuronal
damage
and to do this we take the
five half a million vertices
and slice this model into sections
uh each formed by a smooth
polygon so we have
221 sections
each containing 23 to 277 points
placed at a half millimeter intervals
and together the sections comprising a
a an irregular tubular grid
um
the slices were
were modeled by taking the
mri images uh collapsing the
half millimeter uh set of of points
along each section into a
plane and then modeling the polygon
formed by that set of points this was
done
for all 221 sections uh the sections
become increasingly irregular
toward the middle of the nasal
epithelium as one travels from the front
uh where the uh the
nose hole is uh toward the back uh
where the pharynx is and throat
and using this model then we can uh
define a characteristic placement of
nasal gel
and this is a conservative placement
along
the
wall of the nasal cavity in
two different places but not uh
up to the olfactory epithelium because
we showed that we couldn't directly
inject it
there in a feasible way
but it's conservatively placed insofar
as
the instructions for a nasal gel
generally say to
deposit the material close to the
end of the nose
toward the tip but
then using this placement we can examine
the concentration of zinc that arises by
diffusion
now diffusion occurs
in proportion to the square root of
time and
what we're able to do using uh by
physically modeling the process
diffusion
in a a layer that has the shape of this
uh complicated nasal surface geometry
uh is look at what happens to that
concentration
around the gel as the gel is pushed back
by mucociliary clearance over time
three minutes 10 minutes 20 minutes 60
minutes and here you're seeing the
nasal surface inverted so you're seeing
the apex
at the bottom of this solid
space and our target olfactory
epithelial regions
are shown as blue stripes on the floor
of this
space and the concentration of zinc on a
logarithmic scale
is shown vertically and
what you see is that after the gel is
deposited
the mucociliary clearance generally
avoids nearly all of the olfactory
target areas demonstrating that there is
extremely
low likelihood of significant
olfactory loss due to gel deposition
and and thus low likelihood of aenosmia
as a result
the second area that i have will
illustrate
involves biosurveillance and
[Music]
one of the ways that biosurveillance is
done is by following emergency medical
service events um
that occur in in the united states
and there is a network uh linking
information about these events uh that
are occurring
out of in about half the united states
uh at this point and so the event
specific information is collected on a
near real time basis
and available for analysis
um here you're seeing an ex
as an example a constitutional
syndrome uh uh
occurring in the counties comprising
chicago
uh over 60 to 90 days in the recent past
and uh
what we have here is a summary of how
these kind of
historical patterns of syndromic
occurrence of e m s events
has been characterized for five
different syndromes
and six different locations for urban
areas and two states
um and it's
worth noting that uh syndromes
uh can be apparent evident at the time
of the ems based on the symptoms that
occur
and are observed by the ems personnel
like gi overdose etc
but also syndromes can be
hypothesized based on
symptom symptomatic observations
that are then coded and
posited to be a syndrome such as
the occurrence of covet 19
the source of the the current pandemic
and so here is a
there we go it's a just a summary of the
different kind of historic patterns that
can pertain to these different
locations and syndromes
and these kinds of patterns can be used
to
evaluate whether a recent occurring
event
is anomalous given the history
of similar events in that location
for that syndrome
so there is a
an application of mathematica that's
that's uh
pertinent to biosurveillance and here
uh is a summary of an analysis done to
determine
whether the the hypothesized
um
[Music]
ems events involving the
hypothesized coven 19 syndrome
actually correspond to the cdc reported
incidents of coven 19
in 15 or so different states
[Music]
and all the counties
contained in those states so
we're looking at
weekly occurrences within those counties
and states
cumulative weekly occurrences that are
predicted
using the biosurveillance hypothesized
syndrome of coven 19
versus the cdc reported incidents for
that
county and state and time period
um and
the difference between being that the
ems database allows you near real time
biosurveillance whereas the
cdc incidence is delayed substantially
by the requirement for an actual
diagnosis
after admission to hospital and testing
before the actual incidences
reported out at that level and so you
see
using the hypothesized syndrome you can
get within a factor of five or so
of the actual uh eventually reported
incidents
third is the area of racial disparity
in u.s county level incidents of fatal
police shootings
as summarized by the washington post
police
shooting fatality database covering
2015 through 2020
the mathematica utility here
is that the database uh that's included
uh that that has conv been compiled by
the washington post
includes lat lawn latitude longitude
information for most
events but does not include county
information they have city and state
but not county and to link this
back to census data
a convenient way to do that is to use
u.s census data for
counties during this time period and so
what i did was use mathematica to
interpret the lat lawn data to define
the corresponding counties
for the thousands of rows of data in
these databases
so here you see a summary of incidents
by county per hundred thousand
for unarmed men on on the top figure
here and for
armed men
shot by police on the bottom and so the
both of these patterns
quite clearly show an excess
incidence for black men
compared to white men
this is statistically significant when
analyzed in an odds ratio
manner but here we're looking at
distributions of
incidents and the difference is even
more pronounced
looking at the patterns in this way
particularly for unarmed men where you
see about an eight-fold uh
a difference in in average incidents
and uh then for armed men about a
five-fold
difference uh the odds ratio is about
four
um when analyzed using contingency
tables
using the summary data rather than the
incidents by county
so this is another interesting
application of mathematica
there the mathematica's ability to
interpret lat lawn
positions and and corresponding counties
was a key
utility finally
um mathematica
is something i've used to compare the
plausibility and applicability
of different competing models of cancer
in view of relevant uh experimental
cancer bioassay data
the 75 year old two-stage somatic
mutation
clonal expansion theory of cancer
short or referred to in shorthand as the
somatic mutation
model
views the critical events in cancer to
be
an accumulation of critical
uh mutations of critical oncogenes
so you're damaging dna causing mutations
of critical genes that govern
cell proliferation and
cell suicide are called
apoptosis these are two fundamentally
important processes
that govern cell replication
and oncogenes are known to be associated
with those
two processes
and it's been posited that uh
mutating as few as two critical
oncogenes may be sufficient to generate
a a tumor cell from a normal cell
in
a variety of tissues really
all tissues subject to tumor genesis
and
this model is known more recently as the
mvk model in that
the original model posited shortly after
the structure of dna was
published in 1954 by watson and crick
um um
uh basically laid out this
this uh this interpretation of cancer um
basically used that that information
concerning
dna to infer that as few as
two mutations could lead to
cancer and be consistent with data on
human incidents of cancer
in terms of pattern over time
by allowing for the fact that
pre-cancers or pre-malignant cancers
that have gotten
the first mutation but not the second
could clonally
expand and proliferate before they
acquire the
one of them acquires the second critical
mutation and that generates a pattern
consistent
with most human cancers um
mogadkar uh was the first
and his colleagues uh was the first to
solve the mathematical
version of this model interpreted as a
doubly stochastic
non-homogeneous poisson process
so a process
involving a discrete change and a birth
death
process that allows for
a pre-malignant clonal expansion
followed by a second
critical required change
where the critical mutations are modeled
as poisson events
and you have a birth death process
separating those events
so uh that's not the only theory of
cancer though there have
been a number of theories
that are competed the somatic mutation
is the dominant theory today
it is the behind most of funded cancer
research
but it has been well recognized for many
uh decades that inflammation
plays a critical role in cancer
and an alternative model uh that i have
uh worked on over the last uh
seven ten years or so uh is summarized
here
uh it's something i call the
inflammation somatic mutation
model very similar but here's the
traditional model laid
out vertically you have the two
mutations and a birth
death process here birth and death
uh this this is a subtle but
profound reinterpretation of the model
in that
uh in contrast to the original model
where
any stem cell in any tissue can undergo
these critical changes
and lead to a cancer i am positing that
only a small a normally small subset of
stem cells are relevant
to the process as it typically occurs so
that
cancer is most efficiently formed
only involving a certain subset
of stem cells those that arise
after tissue injury is followed by
inflammation and the inflammatory immune
cells
then work as they are now known to do to
activate local stem cells and actually
orchestrate the process
of tissue repair
which is involves an epigenetic
conversion
not dna damage not mutations but
something that does not involve mutation
per se but affects how genes
are are translated uh
the importance of epigenetics
to biology and cancer was only
recognized
in the 1990s with nobel prizes awarded
in the
mid-2000s
there's a exploding literature showing
how epigenetic dysregulation can
seems to be an important factor in
cancer
this postulates how this could actually
occur
well it turns out
an important rat bioassay study
was published in 2014 by
a group at dartmouth and johns hopkins
studying uh chemo prevention of
aflatoxin-induced liver cancer
so aflatoxin is a
chemical associated with molds of grains
it is a potent carcinogen particularly
to liver
but also other tissues known to be a
potent rat carcinogen and also a highly
potent mutagen
damages dna it binds onto dna
makes it difficult to replicate causes
damage and mutations
so it's always been thought that the
mutations are what cause the
tumors but this group
compared rats exposed to aflatoxin only
when
they are young juveniles for four weeks
um they expose them to enough
uh aflatoxin to give nearly all of them
liver cancer and then they compared
those rats to
a similarly exposed group
exposed to aflatoxin the same way but
also
exposed to a very potent
anti-inflammatory tri-terpenoid agent
and after that they looked at dna damage
and liver tumors
so the amazing thing about this study is
that
compared to all the liver cancer shown
in the aflatoxin exposed group the group
that got the same aflatoxin at the same
time
but also at the early juvenile stage was
also exposed to the anti-inflammatory
agent
got no liver tumors
and the issue is uh well how could that
be unless the
the anti-inflammatory agent prevented
all the mutations uh
how could this be um well in fact they
looked at the
aflatoxin adducts that cause the
mutations and they were not decreased
enough
to explain this by any means
and what i did recently was to
use the the uh doubly stochastic
poisson model of the current
dominant theory of tumor genesis to show
how that model is perfectly consistent
with the
aflatoxin exposed group of rat results
it cannot explain how
the studies observe zero tumors
with the exposure with the co-exposure
to the anti-inflammatory agent
and here you see the background
incidence of
liver tumors in the same kind of rat
studies very rare
you wouldn't see any you wouldn't hope
to see any in about 20 rats
uh you need about 500 rats to see
a liver tumor
and and here what you see
is the binomial upper 95
confidence limit on a proportion of 0
out of twenty
and you see that's the confidence bound
and
the the two stage model the mvk model
assuming it reduced the mutation rates
as much as that which was observed
in the study um was only able to
predict a reduction in liver tumor
incidence
here at the end of life whereas in fact
the rats showed zero liver tumor so
the alternative model that i
proposed predicts instead that by
blocking inflammation
the the anti-inflammatory agent impedes
the activation of tumor relevant stem
cells and that explains the absence of
liver tumors
from this study so four ways of using
mathematica
to investigate uh toxicology and
environmental health
and i'll leave it at that and take
questions
thank you